و معنا الان من خان يونس الصحفي اسماعيل
ابو عمر
اسماعيل نحب ان نسمع منك المستجدات في خان
يونس تحديدا
تفضل نعم الساعات السابقه كانت ساعات صعبه
هنا في خانيونس خاصه مع توغل اليات
الاحتلال لمسافات جديده ومساحات جديده في
منطقه جنوب وسط المحافظه وكذلك الجنوب
الشرقي لمحافظه خانيونس خلال الساعات
الماضيه منذ منتصف الليل وحتى هذه اللحظه
القصف المدفعي لم يهدا للحظه ويتركز في
منطقه جيزان النجار الى الجنوب من محافظه
خانيونس هذه المنطقه هي منطقه جديده تدخل
الى منطقه عمليات الجيش الاسرائيلي في هذا
الصباح هناك في هذه المنطقه هي منطقه
زراعيه بالطبع لكن عدد من المواطنين في
تلك المنطقه محاصرين جراء القصف المدفعي و
وكذلك اطلاق النار الكثيف من قبل اليات
الاحتلال والغارات العنيفه التي تنفذها
بين الحين والاخر طائرات الاحتلال خلال
الليله الماضيه هناك اكثر من 20 غاره
واحزمه ناريه نفذتها طائرات الاحتلال في
تلك المنطقه وفي هذا الصباح اليات
الاحتلال تواجدت على الارض في منطقه جزان
النجار اضافه الىى منطقه جورت اللوت
المجاوره لهذه المنطقه الى الجنوب الشرقي
من محافظه خانيونس اعم الدخان تتصاعد من
كل المحاور في شمال شرق المحافظه اس ماذا
عن المنازل اذا سمحت لي هل هناك تفاصيل
بشان المنازل التي استهدفت في حي المناره
تحديدا والتي سقط بسببها ثمانيه شهداء نعم
ثمانيه شهداء في استهداف عده منازل تم نقل
هؤلاء الشهداء الى مستشفى غزه الاوروبي
اضافه الى اكثر من 15 اصابه وصلت الى
مستشفى غزه الاوروبي نتيجه هذا القصف الى
جانب القصف المدفع للمنازل هناك ايضا
مواطنون نازحون في مدرسه من منطقه جيزان
النجار وحتى هذه اللحظه عالقون داخل هذه
المدرسه لا يستطيعون التحرك بسبب غزاره
النيران التي تطلقها اليات الاحتلال وكذلك
القصف المدفعي العنيف بين الحين والاخر في
محيط هذه المدرسه شهود عيان نجحوا من
نجحوا بال بالنجاه من تلك المنطقه ووصلوا
الى مستشفى غزه الاوروبي وتحدثوا بان قوات
الاحتلال قامت ايضا باعتقال عدد من
المواطنين من داخل منطقه جيزان النجار
خاصه من عائله النجار وايضا هناك عمليات
قصف تستهدف محيط تلك المدرسه ما يصعب خروج
هؤلاء المواطنين والنازحين الذين لجوا الى
هذه المدرسه بعد ان ضاقت بهم السبل لا
توجد اماكن امنه او اماكن يلجؤون اليها
بخلاف هذه المدرسه واصروا على البقاء برغم
ضراوه النيران من حولهم والان هم محاصرون
وعالقون وا الاخبار عنهم يعني لا تصلنا
حتى هذه اللحظه حول مصير هؤلاء الناس داخل
المدرسه مدرسه ابو بكر الصديق تحديدا في
في منطقه جيزان النجار الى الجنوب من
خانيونس اعداد الشهداء تتزا تتزايد وكذلك
الاصابات نتيجه القصف المدفع واطلاق النار
بين الحين والاخر هناك انتشال لشهداء جدد
في مناطق متعدده من محافظه خنوس خاصه في
وسط المحافظه مع استمرار القصف المدفعي في
مستشفى ناصر تم انتشال عدد من الشهداء
وكذلك عدد من الاصابات وصلوا الى المستشفى
قبل قليل والاخبار التي تردنا في المناطق
الجنوبيه الشرقيه حتى هذه اللحظه محدوده
جدا نظ لان تلك المنطقه اضافه الى عمليات
القصف المدفعي واطلاق النار هناك تقييد
على حركه المواطنين في تلك المنطقه سواء
من الخ بالخروج منها او حتى الدخول اليها
واصبحت هذه المنطقه منطقه محاصره ومعزوله
من من جنوب شرق محافظه خانيونس وانت تتحدث
اسماعيل ك نشاهد صورا ل مشاهد الدمار
الكبير والخراب في خان يونس هذه الصور
وصلتنا قبل قليل اشكرك اسماعيل
ابو عمر من خان يونس على هذه
التفاصيل